[Music]
very good morning to you there are
warnings that
some nhs trusts in england could take up
to
five years to clear the backlog caused
by the pandemic
nhs providers say the number of
postponed operations is the highest it's
seen since the beginning of the century
and the warning of similar delays in a
range of services let's talk to our
correspondent ashley haranak who's in
the newsroom with all the details and
who is likely to be most affected by
this ashna
we know at the heart of this stephen
there are going to be many patients
millions of them in fact we know are
waiting
when it comes to facing some sort of
hospital treatment
and whilst it does say nhs providers the
urgent care they are tackling very
quickly
hospitals in the in england that is they
are still facing huge backlogs when it
comes to a variety of services let's
take you through who exactly
is affected by this the first one that
they say is cancer care those are some
of the services which are impacted not
necessarily
referrals but those waiting to start
treatment the other one is elective
surgery things
like hip and knee replacement spinal
surgery nose and throat procedures too
but there are also concerns about
other areas less visible backlogs in
mental health and community services the
nhs providers
organizations say they've heard from
trusts that have told them it could take
them some
three to five years to try and clear
this backlog the detail in this
is new but we had reported on friday
that there are
4.7 million people in england waiting to
start some form of hospital treatment
that figure is accurate up until the end
of february february
i also uh spoke on friday um to one of
the 387
000 people who have been waiting over a
year to
have a routine procedure this particular
woman i spoke to was waiting to have
spinal surgery
and we were told on friday that this
could be a multi-year challenge
um they have suggested some solutions
though if i take you through some of
them the nhs providers have said the
first one is increasing capacity
increasing the size of the workforce we
know the nhs as a whole has been
quite overstretched particularly in the
last year we've seen that
um full frontal really the restructuring
of hospitals is the other one so they're
better prepared to deal with further
covered waves
and annual winter struggles it's
particularly a difficult time for them
we know the other one is improving
efficiency
with trusts working together more
cohesively
um we heard on friday the nhs england
acknowledged that they have had
400 000 covered 19 patients over the
past year it's no
wonder that has had an impact on
services but they do say that in january
and february which was their
busiest months in throughout the whole
of the pandemic they still managed to
undertake
some two million routine procedures in
the last few moments we have heard
stephen
from the department of health and they
have told us that
we are backing the nhs with an extra
seven billion
pounds they say for health and care
services that includes of course
a covert 19 recovery fund but that will
cost them
one billion pounds to help the nhs try
and recover from the
brutal year that we've had okay
thank you well let's talk to the chief
executive of nhs providers chris hopson
good to see you this morning this seven
billion pounds of we presume extra
funding
coming from the government what
difference is that going to make to try
and resolve this issue
well stephen when we talk about um nhs
funding um
it's easy to kind of confuse different
bits so that that is the extra money
that the nhs is getting this year to
meet
covid costs which is very welcome but
that's a completely different issue to
the multi-year costs in other words the
cost next year the year after and the
year after
that we're going to need to meet and
clear this backlog so
it's important to just say that this
isn't just about money it's actually
about the nhs
is going to need to transform the way it
provides care
because we are going to have very very
uh uh
big backlog here i mean our trusts have
been looking over the last month
about how that backlog a big big that
backlog will be we still don't know the
actual size yet
because there were a bunch of uh
patients who we would have expected to
be referred over the last 12
months who haven't been referred because
of covid so we still don't know the full
size of the problem but what's becoming
clear in the work our trusts have done
over the last month
is that we have got a really big backlog
here so what we're going to need to do
is create a plan
between ourselves and the government
with us working out how we're going to
transform care and speed up getting
through that backlog
and the government putting in extra
funding i mean
it's interesting to be in a situation
where we have such a big backlog
without anyone pointing the finger of
blame because it's just
you know what has happened after the
terrible year that we've had does
because no one is is blaming anybody for
this
does that mean it gives you a slightly
sort of
wider remit to look at how you tackle
with it
tackle this issue well i think there's
two things to say the
the the first is that we must never
forget the patient uh and
it was good to hear um your colleague
refer to
a patient story somebody she'd been
speaking to and certainly whenever i
talk to our trust leaders what they're
really clear about
is that um you know one one person
having to wait
any longer than they need to is a
problem and they're really really
committed to making sure that we get
through this backlog as quickly as
possible
but yes you're right i think it's really
important that we understand that
you know we've got a backlog not because
the nhs hasn't been doing its job it's
actually been doing its job extremely
well
we actually recovered services uh last
autumn
um much quicker actually than we were
expecting
but because of covert and we've had this
disruption
and as soon as you get more covered
every single one of our trust leaders
says look
the only way we can cope with this is
for example turning operating theaters
into temporary um you know covered areas
where we can treat the sickest patient
so
as soon as you get covered the reality
is you have to cut back on the amount of
for example elective surgery that you're
doing
so yes i i think the real opportunity
here is i think you put it really well
in your question stephen is that
um we do have an opportunity here to do
things differently and
you know you'll remember that over the
particularly in the early 2000s we had a
similar
problem and the way we tackled it then
was effectively we did lots of overtime
we used the private sector
we had a kind of ruthless focus on
cutting waiting lists and the reality
i'm afraid is that
a we've got many more priorities now we
absolutely
have to deliver the long-term plan nhs
long-term plan we've got to work out how
we uh
live long-term with covid so we haven't
just got a small number of priorities
we've got a much larger number of
priorities and the real issue is that
actually um we're gonna have to do
things differently if we just try and do
it the same way we did it back in the
early 2000s
we're not going to get through this
quick enough we do know though that
every time there's any sort of
attempted restructuring of the nhs it
hits an
awful lot of opposition now i guess the
difference with this case would be
normally
it's coming from the guff it's coming
top down from the government saying
things need to be changed
i mean this is coming from you and
proposing it to the government
does that mean there is going to be more
of a willingness amongst
trusts and staff to do things
differently
yeah i think there's a real recognition
and i um that we do need to do things
differently and hey stephen one of the
great things that i think we've all
learned over the last 12 months and it's
one of our big learning points of covid
is that actually
the nhs can transform much more quickly
and much more effectively than we might
previously have believed so
you know you and i have spoken on at
least a couple of occasions about the
fantastic success of the vaccination
campaign
we've had to completely reconfigure
ourselves to deliver that vaccination
campaign
back last march this time last year we
actually produced 30
000 beds for covid patients luckily they
weren't all needed
but you know that again you know we
demonstrated that we can transform a
pace so the deal here is
and there does need to be a really clear
deal which is
we need to step up to the plate in the
nhs in terms of transforming the way
that we do things
but the government's got to provide the
extra funding and i'm afraid
what's currently available won't be
sufficient yes they have given us that
extra billion
that the department was talking about
the um um that your colleague was
talking about earlier
but that's only for this year and it's
only the first installment
of the extra funding that's going to be
needed here so that's what we've got to
do
over the next few months is work
together on what's the plan to tackle
this
but you know just briefly chris i mean
the problem that you've got is with a
backlog of
say five million has sort of rounded up
um
if the pandemic situation stopped today
you've got an absolutely exhausted
workforce
and now this huge backlog to deal with
as well i mean how
how do you deal with all of this and
take care of the welfare of your
teams well that's exactly the challenge
that our trust leaders are doing
are working through at the moment
they're really identifying exactly
how they can make both those things work
at once because the reality is is that
you can't
you can't recover a backlog if you
haven't got the staff um
available to provide the care so that's
exactly what we're trying to do is is
ensure that our staff have the space to
decompress and
uh and have a bit of recovery but then
at the same time what we're doing at the
moment is getting through the most
urgent cases but
having the right workforce model to get
through all of this uh backlog is going
to be fundamental
chris hopson good to talk to you thank
you good to start you stephen thank you
now well after a year of coronavirus
restrictions crowds will return to
football stadiums today
wembley is the first with a small number
of fans at the fa cup semi-final between
leicester and southampton
4 000 people in attendance tickets
limited to local residents and key
workers
now it's one of the government's pilot
events which started with the world
snooker championships
in sheffield and music fans in liverpool
will be allowed
into a near normal gig next month 5 000
people attending a concert in sefton
park
there will be no social distancing and
no face coverings
but those who attend will have to
provide a negative
test in advance
the u.s climate change envoys told sky
news that global warming is now beyond
catastrophic
john kerry was speaking in china and the
united after the united states and china
agreed stronger rules to combat the
problem and saying they should be
introduced before the end of the year
mr kerry told sophie ridge world leaders
must
act now well it's extremely urgent uh
i mean the word urgent is is totally
applicable to the current crisis that
we're in because
countries are simply not getting the job
done
uh even if we did everything that we set
out to do in the paris agreement
the earth's temperature is going to
increase a very significant amount
perhaps as much as 3.7 degrees or more
and the reason and the reason for the
real urgency now is that
because we're not getting done what we
said we do in paris it's actually
heading towards four degrees or more
that's beyond catastrophic in the
consequences to food production
water habitability in various parts of
the planet the melting of ice the sea
level rise
the warming all the consequences so we
have an opportunity to get on track
the united states has a summit next week
the president biden is hosting
and we will be setting forth our plan to
try to do our part
and we hope to raise ambition among all
nations over the course of these next
months
and just to remind you about the daily
climate show
back tomorrow half past six and half
past nine
now people around the world have taken
part in
services for the duke of edinburgh he
was buried during a ceremony at windsor
castle yesterday and
while the numbers allowed to attend in
person were small the service was shown
around
the world katarina vertozzi reports
for all the pomp and the pageantry
this felt personal touches of the duke
everywhere
for those watching at home these were
the first glimpses of the queen
since prince philip's death entering st
george's chapel
a solitary figure
inside distance from her family and
masked
however public a figure this was still a
private service
in pandemic times
outside of the castle walls there was
admittedly little to see but the people
who were here
could hear the music and the cannon fire
and they took part in a minute of
silence that despite all the
restrictions
still felt deeply moving
i feel like it's the right thing to have
done for people to be
able to come up and just be all together
really because it's a shame we can't all
be together inside and
as one as england always do
[Music]
it was of course not just england where
this moment was marked
uh
okay
ah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
a life come full circle celebrated
mourned
and remembered
caterina sky news
well also in the headlines this morning
police in the czech republic say they
want to question
two russian men suspected of carrying
out the poisoning of sergey skripal in
salisbury
they're wanted in connection with an
explosion at an arms depot in 2014
police say met the men were in the
country at the time of the attack
in which two people died the russian
opposition leader alexei navalny is said
to be on the verge of death as he
continues his hunger strike in prison
doctors say the politician is at high
risk of a heart attack
after being refused medical treatment
and turning to starvation in
protest now just to warn you you might
find these images a little bit
distressing
safety regulators in the united states
have released footage of a child being
dragged under a treadmill
and warned customers to stop using
certain machines
now the pictures from the u.s consumer
product safety commission
show the youngster falling under the
peloton tread
plus machine he survived but officials
say another child has died in an
incident with the same machine
peliton insists the warning is
inaccurate and
misleading
now something that hopefully will put a
smile on your face this morning we'll
show you
dexter oh
lesson dexter has learned to walk again
after suffering
some severe injuries as a puppy he was
hit by a car
and badly injured his two front legs oh
god i love him
now five years later and after a few
operations he's adapted
and now goes out for regular walks with
his owner in colorado where he is
a bit of a local celebrity oh look at
that
look at that god love him
how he manages i mean that's quite
impressive
that is quite impressive blessing
uh reminds me of you in the mornings
when you come in i'm not that steady
no that's true actually not to live out
of coffee
after a coffee what's happening this
morning um a little bit of everything
lots of sunshine out there this morning
again a chilly start
but some areas seeing some rain today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning for the vast majority again
today it is going to
be largely fine and dry with lots of
sunshine and actually feeling quite warm
in the sunshine too compared to the
cooler conditions
that we've experienced earlier in the
week but there is also going to be some
rain around for today
which is probably good news not too much
rain but
we haven't really seen much of it at all
this month we are well below
average for what we'd expect for this
time of year so
at the moment cloudy with rain across
ireland northern ireland
western scotland elsewhere mainly dry
and sunny but chilly
continuing that way into this afternoon
lots of sunshine for wales england the
south and east of scotland feeling warm
in the sunshine too but a cloudier out
towards western areas later turning the
sunshine hazy staying cloudy with patchy
rain for ireland northern ireland
and western scotland quite breezy over
these areas too
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
a doctor from syria who's treating covet
patients in england has warned the nhs
is facing a mental health pandemic
amongst its staff
dr mohammed kajug has been talking to
our reporter
salia chowdhury
aleppo a city ravaged by years of war
and one of the hardest places in the
world to be a medic
and it's here at the dara shifa hospital
that muhammad kaju trained to become a
doctor
today he's fighting another kind of
battle against
covid19 in a hospital in york
he's done this for months and he's
exhausted
everyone here is i will always remember
the first coveted patient
isa in emergency department you can't
just
forget someone who repeatedly saying
i can't breathe i can't breathe he's a
doctor who knows about losing the fight
for life
working in a hospital that could be
pumped and
attacked at any moment he's experienced
appalling pain and agony
his experienced loss when the hospital
was attacked severely
and completely destroyed we couldn't get
anyone
alive all of them were dead more than 30
people i realized
my best friend died
the hardest part of the job whichever
front line he's on
is always the same to prioritize
patients
and decide to leave whoever you think
you can't do anything for them because
their injuries are just like too
complicated
and you don't think they will make it no
matter what you do for them
today there are rising concerns of
post-traumatic stress disorder amongst
nhs staff
and calls for an urgent plan to address
mental health issues
which experts say could last years after
the immediate threat of the virus has
gone
most people will remember kermit as a
lockdown and not being
able to function as normal for
healthcare workers it's completely
different matter
they will carry on having memories of
patients
they couldn't help they could see them
dying in front of their eyes
not being able to do anything like many
on the front line dr khajud tries to
find peace
and calm away from the constant pressure
of the emergency rooms
[Music]
it doesn't last for long in this crisis
but he knows about pressure and the
lessons he learnt in syria
are now part of britain's fight against
covid19
sadia chowdhury sky news in york
well these are the latest coronavirus
figures from the department of health
and 2206 new cases have been reported
along with 35 more deaths now that
brings the total number of people who've
died within 28 days of a positive test
to 127 thousand
hundred another 119
306 had their first vaccine and 485
4421 had their second that means
42 million injections have now been
given out across the uk
now after a year of coronavirus
restrictions crowds returned to the
football today
wembley is first with a small number of
fans at the fa cup semi-final between
leicester and southampton
4 000 people there with tickets limited
to local residents and key workers
it's one of the government's pilot
events that started with the world
snooker championship in sheffield and
music fans in liverpool will be allowed
into a near normal gig
next month five thousand people
attending a concert in sefton park there
will be
no social distancing and no face
coverings how weird is that gonna feel
but ticket holders will have to provide
a negative
test in advance
now the struggles of homeless people
have been heightened by the pandemic
with government schemes and charities
trying to help those in need one
volunteer
group in salford are putting themselves
in the shoes of people they support
by sleeping rough for 48 hours where
we're
joined by the co-founder of two brews
pete lock good morning to you
what difference does it make for for
volunteers
to to put themselves through this
morning
um yeah we i mean we decided to
to do this want to raise money and raise
awareness but to
also see it through through their eyes
and and
try to experience what they they go
through on a day-to-day basis and
it's been pretty tough i'm not gonna lie
it's uh it's been an eye-opening
experience
which is i mean it's interesting isn't
it that you know something
which is you know an experience and you
know and pretty tough
for you is something that people have to
go through
every night of the week it does put it
all into some sort of perspective
doesn't it
it does yeah i mean we've been fairly
fortunate the weather's been really nice
the last couple of days
um but on a day-to-day basis it must be
so so hard for them i mean
manchester's alive all the time 24 hours
a day is these people passing through
and disturbing you so
i don't know how they sleep to be honest
we've not had much sleep and
we've let's say we've had it quite mild
what do you think is happening in terms
of the homeless situation in a city like
manchester so much was done to try to
get people off the streets during the
pandemics
um are those efforts waning now do you
think
yeah not enough to be honest uh it's
frightening
we're getting more and more new faces we
we send an outreach teamwork every
single night with about 100 meals
and hot drinks and we're getting more
and more
new faces all the time and
there does need to be more action put
into places
more support networks to help them
because it's a growing growing issue
well i mean who are the people that
you've been seeing over the
you know the last few weeks or so when
you've been out and about
who are the people who are sleeping
homeless because i do think you
often we we have a misconception about
who these people are and what their
backgrounds are don't we
yeah you i'm a mixed bag of everybody to
be honest
a lot of people are finding themselves
on the streets now though because of the
pandemic you might have lost a job
and just different situations you come
across people from
all different walks of life it's not
people's stereotype
homelessness anybody is a couple of
mispay packets away from ending up in
this situation so
that's why we formed and that's what
we're trying to combat
and make people aware of so in terms of
the fundraising
that i mean that you no doubt do all the
time but with this particular
uh 48 hours what do you actually
what are you going to do with that i
mean is it a case of providing
direct support to these people
it's going to be spent on ongoing costs
to be honest i mean
like i say making 100 100 meals a night
and
we support them by sleeping bags clothes
tents
but we we also try and help signpost and
you know get them the support that they
need to actually
get them off the streets isn't just
about feeding them it's about
trying to get them let's say in a better
place
what what i mean how difficult is it to
to provide
people just with with enough of a
stepping stone
to get off the streets and to get back
into accommodation and
and start to build a life back up again
it's really really difficult to be
honest
it goes on what borah so depending on
what bureau you're in
and so people come into the city centre
to be fed
but they might not necessarily be from
the city centre you might be from
the outer regions and i think it needs
what needs to happen is it needs
the people who need to get the support
all under one
umbrella so that they can be signed
posted to the right places rather than
being
passed from pillar to post well look
pete um good luck with the rest of it
and and thank you for for talking to us
and again raising awareness of this
issue which
is too easily forgotten amongst a lot of
us so
it's good to talk to you thank you
brilliant thanks sea time
okay let's go check on the weather for
you with nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's looking fine for many
areas once again today we've got high
pressure
keeping hold of that settled weather but
there is going to be a bit of rain but
actually it's much needed because so far
this month we are well below average in
terms of rainfall totals
across the uk for the time of year
so currently patchy rain cloudy skies
and rather breezy over island northern
ireland western scotland but it's not so
cold across these areas thanks to the
cloud cover in comparison to wales
england
eastern parts of scotland where it's
chilly frosty as well
but lots of sunshine and the sunshine
continues into this afternoon feeling
warm much like yesterday
in any sunny spells a bit cloudier later
for parts of wales western england up
towards eastern parts of scotland
turning that sunshine hazy but staying
dry over these parts
whereas for western scotland northern
ireland the republic a cloudy breezy day
quite cool with patchy rain to the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nas thank you still to come for you this
morning we'll take you through the
papers with russell myers from the
mirror
and the founder of the crown chronicles
victoria howard
to have a look through the papers once
again with the mirrors royal editor
russell myers and the founder of the
crown
chronicles victoria howard morning both
um to the uh
mail on sunday russell looking at what
the two as they call
fascinating cameos we may not have
spotted
at the funeral yesterday
yes indeed well this is quite an
interesting take on uh on
funeral yesterday because when you're
faced with such a
massive occasion of national importance
and and international attention it's
often
quite difficult to spot the uh the
little instances which are very very
interesting and they take
a look at the the flowers that were used
which were
hand hand-picked by the queen the
soprano who was absolutely incredible
who was drafted in because of course
not only were the uh the mourners
limited to to a number of 30 but of
course the choir had to be limited as
well so there was only four
singers in the choir that rang out
throughout saint george's chapel but
the most interesting uh point was when
the uh the carriage that the duke of
edinburgh
used to ride around in windsor uh castle
and district
um was actually used in the ceremony and
as a tribute they placed his hat his
loves
and his whip in the carriage as it rode
into windsor castle
and also the little box of sugar lumps
that he used to feed
the horses as well so just a wonderful
wonderful tribute to a to
a remarkable man yes because you won't
have missed that if you were watching
sky news yesterday
with a wonderful wonderful commentary
for alistar bruce who
who pointed out it was the sugar lump
box there's nothing he doesn't know let
me tell you
uh sunday express victoria um looking at
william and harry
together absolutely
i think many people were kind of
anticipating that reunite
reunion of the the brothers of course
they've not spoken face-to-face in over
a year so
the express kind of looks at it as kate
bringing them together
and this is more of an observation but
we saw
and the duke and duchess of cambridge
and then the duke of sussex walking
up back to the private apartments of
windsor
and it seems that kate engages in some
conversation with harry
and then she leaves them and the
brothers kind of talk alone
but it's so key of course the the public
way in which
uh harry and megan discuss ongoings
within the royal family in that open
interview
not all that long ago and of course such
a somber occasion being the first time
they meet face to face
so many people on social media were
talking about this saying that you know
this is really positive
and i do think that as for many families
across the world
a death in the family is kind of a
chance to reflect and
maybe patch things up if they've not
been too too good in recent times
excuse me in recent times so i do think
that um we're hopefully
some progress there and i think the the
wider family is also invested in that
being um
repaired as well well let's hope so
because i mean forget the royal side of
it they're a family
and they're brothers and it's always
better if brothers can can get along
to the sunday mirror russell looking at
i mean and
the the picture which is framed all of
this is that one of the queen
in the choir on her own and the sunday
mirror looking at how
at the end of the day you know she is a
widow
now yes of course uh one of a number of
striking
images from yesterday and it's also the
main image on our front page today
uh the queen cutting a very solitary
figure on her own not only because of
the fact that you know her beloved
husband of 73 years
has left her but also because of this
service was ravaged by the coronavirus
restrictions and
this is a fantastic piece by one of our
senior writers
rachel bletchley and entitled behind the
invisible armor of duty
the monarch was simply a grieving widow
and certainly
there have been many many hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people
around the world have had to face
similar circumstances and certainly the
uh the queen and the royal family were
very
keen uh to stand to shoulder shoulder
with those people that have
had to face this on their own um
certainly an extraordinary set of
circumstances have led to this and um
those images will live long in the
memory i'm sure
yeah yeah no i'm quite right um to the
sunday telegraphic jory i mean
what now for the queen as a widow how
how do we think it's going to change
everyday life
well of course she's 95 this coming week
so i think we can definitely
expect to see to see less of her
essentially of course covid still isn't
over
yet um but i i think more than anything
we'll be seeing more of the younger
roles including prince charles
not not so much on the young side and
but just taking over
more and more of those duties um
widowhood is something i'll see a lot of
people are having to contend with in
this last year because of the
the pandemic and it's something that is
a universal experience in grief
at one point in particular i saw on
social media which i thought was
hugely poignant and interesting was that
this funeral actually gave the nation a
chance to to mourn
and grieve together not only for the
duke but for those hundreds of thousands
of people
who have lost their lives in the
pandemic and those people who weren't
able to attend the funerals because of
such restrictions
and i think that really resonated and
will resonate with people across the uk
um i'm sure it will as you say nearly
very nearly 128
000 now it's an awful lot of families
affected but can we finish off with
um uh victoria looking at a bit of
spelling
because it's the it's the bane of a lot
of people's lives a bit of spelling but
are we gonna have to focus more on it
it seems that the rules might be
shifting so the uh sunday times report
that there might be some new rules in
the uh in the making to help simplify
the english language
i see from the headline there rules are
spelled with two o's instead of u-l-e-s
and it's basically because english as a
language takes up to three years longer
to learn at primary school level
than many other languages because of the
irregularity of
it so the they're hoping to to move to
this trend uh traditional
uh spelling revised system uh which will
hopefully repair broken spelling so we
can
expect to see you know those those
silent letters and words like wrong
and nash to be removed and spelling
hopefully simplified in terms of
as that example of rules there no
no no no victoria this can't be right
this cannot be right surely
so language so me personally i'm a
german speaker as well which is why i
find this so
interesting that they're for many other
languages they kind of have councils and
systems in place to regulate languages
english doesn't really have that and
it's just kind of a bit of a hodgepodge
over the centuries
of things crawling in so the american
english for example example that had a
simplification which is why
they dropped the u from things like
color and favorite
um so this is super super interesting um
i kind of see it almost like potentially
the change we had you know that shift
that
i'm i'm so disturbed victoria i'm gonna
have to stop you both
right there it's been good to see you
this morning thank you
you